how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and
all things relating to the MCU now the
future of the MCU is very very exciting
and very bright despite the current
pandemic that we're all living in right
now eventually things will be normal ish
and eventually Marvel's first family and
the Fantastic Four will make their way
into the MCU and it seems like it's
going to be in a movie that fans are
very excited for but don't realize just
how important it is and that is ant-man
3 now today we have reports of what
Marvel's plans are for ant-man 3 and
they do involve the Fantastic Four and
The Young Avengers which I did a video
on yesterday but this new report tells
us that the Fantastic Four are coming to
the MCU soon which coincides with what
Kevin Feige said at the end of Marvel's
panel at San Diego comic-con of 2019 so
let's dive into it if you're new be sure
to subscribe to stay up to date with all
Marvel content and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 I'm picking a winner and 550,000
subscribers only 5,000 more to go so
today's report comes from the website
the geeks worldwide they have broken
many scoops in the past before and
recently their senior editor Thomas
Pulido has posted concerning Ant Man 3
and he has said that he has discovered
that before
Jeff loveness who was a writer and
co-producer of the Rick and Morty TV
show had been hired to write Ant Man 3
Paul Rudd originally wrote a script for
a man 3 his direct quote is a for Jeff
loveness came aboard Paul Rudd wrote an
ant-man 3 script that featured modock
and aim not only that but Marvel
originally wanted the Fantastic Four in
the film but now they're pursuing the
possibility of including the young
Avengers now there is a pretty big
tie-in and connection between the
Fantastic Four and ant-man and it seems
like ant-man is actually going to be
setting up a lot more for the MCU than
fans think not only are the Fantastic
Four going to possibly be in the film
and/or set up in ant-man 3 but it's also
most likely going to tease or
up Kang the Conqueror zem Cu appearance
and I'll break down and talk about just
how all of this is going to happen in
ant-man 3 so if you remember back before
Avengers endgame came out right after
the release of ant-man and the wasp
Marvel Studios revealed something that
is very very important to the future of
the MCU it's in the scene where Hank Pym
and Janet Van Dyne are leaving the
quantum realm the kind folks over at
Marvel told us to freeze-frame on a
particular scene in which it revealed a
quantum city now obviously this was very
intentionally placed even though you
have to freeze frame the scene to see it
and you can only see it for about a
second but it's because of those reasons
that Marvel made sure to include it in
the movie and then tell us about it
which make it so important now we
originally thought that this was going
to have a pretty big impact on avengers
endgame but obviously we all saw the
movie and it didn't play any role in the
movie at all but Marvel still told us
about it which means it's going to have
a very very important role to play in
ant-man 3 now the reason that this
quantum city is going to be so important
in ant-man 3 and so important to the
future of the MCU is because the
Fantastic Four are most likely in the
quantum city and its most likely Kang
the Conqueror who put them there and
trap them there now it's been widely
speculated for a very long time that the
Fantastic Four we're going to make their
debut in ant-man 3 because of the
quantum city and now we have
confirmation from this report that that
is what Marvel was planning to do now
they may have deterred a little bit from
it but it does seem like they plan to
have the Fantastic Four be inside of
that city and here's the story of how
that happens now originally the
Fantastic Four get their powers from
space by being exposed to cosmic rays
but in the MCU it seems like that's
going to be changed now in the MCU it
seems like they're going to be getting
their powers from the quantum realm now
if you recall at the end of ant-man and
the wasp Janet Van Dyne comes out of the
quantum realm and she has powers now and
she explains that while you're in the
quantum realm it starts to change you
thirty years ago Henry this place it
changes you an adaptation is part of it
but some of it is evolution and as you
can see right after she mentions how the
quantum realm changes you she flies
right past the quantum city that means
Hank Pym picked her up right next to the
city which means that is most likely
where she was and if she was in a whole
city she has definitely met some people
in the Fantastic Four were probably some
of those people now as far as how they
got their ghost that is most likely due
to King now for those of you who may not
know Kang the Conqueror his real name is
Nathaniel Richards and he's a great
descendant of Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four mr. fantastic and the
comics Nathaniel Richards is actually
from the future in an alternate timeline
he creates a time-travel machine and
begins to time-travel to many different
universes he goes back to ancient times
and at one point he builds a base in
limbo called kanopolis now there's two
very interesting parts about kanopolis
one as I just said was he creates it in
limbo now when you start to dive into
time-travel it can get pretty messy but
Avengers in game use the quantum realm
as the means to time travel
so therefore if there was a limbo so to
speak in time it would be the quantum
realm because as we've learned from Hank
Pym and ant-man the quantum realm is a
place where time and space don't really
operate the same way they do in the real
world not to mention ant-man was
actually stuck in the quantum realm he
was stuck in limbo so to speak at the
end of ant-man and the wasp and before
Avengers endgame he was stuck until the
true hero of the movie the rat stepped
on the button bringing him back but the
fact that cranapple as' exists in limbo
isn't the only hint that the Fantastic
Four are stuck there if you take a look
at a picture of Crenn apalis in the
comics and you compare it to this
quantum city that we saw an ant man on
the wasp they actually look very very
similar primarily due to the fact that
they are very large at Grandda cities
and they both have a giant dome over
them so this does appear to be cranapple
as' which means that it is created by
Kang the Conqueror
since Kang is the master of time-travel
he's clearly realized that the quantum
realm is the way to do it and now
it seems like in the MCU he has set up
an entire city inside of the quantum
room a base that exists between time
that way he can go to whatever point in
time that he wants to and it can do it
right from the city now as far as King a
wanting to capture the Fantastic Four
and keep them inside of there goes King
actually has a lot of resentment and
bitterness towards the Fantastic Four
when Kang originally learns how to time
travel he goes back in time to ancient
Egypt he makes himself the ruler over
Egypt and he calls himself Rama Tut but
his rule is cut short by a time
displaced fantastic for ever since then
he's been very bitter with the Fantastic
Four and has fought them many many
different times which is why he could
have captured them and have placed them
in his quantum city in the quantum realm
right now but we have to remember that
nathaniel richards is originally from a
thousand years into the future so if he
caught the Fantastic Four in our current
timeline that means they probably
wouldn't have their powers yet so King
himself by bringing the Fantastic Four
inside of the quantum realm is actually
giving them their powers now Kang is the
one villain that is going to be perfect
for tying the entirety of the new Marvel
Cinematic Universe together we have the
New Avengers coming up
The Young Avengers coming up and then of
course we now have the x-men and the
Fantastic Four coming into the MCU as
well and Kang throughout his time has
had dealings with everyone Kang the
Conqueror made his debut in Fantastic
Four number 19 but he is also one of the
most iconic Avengers villains of all
time he is no doubt a Thanos level
villain and not only that but he also
has a major tie-in to the x-men as well
when Kang first goes back in time to
ancient Egypt and becomes the Pharaoh
Rama Tut he takes on an apprentice
someone that he plans to be his heir and
that person is in Saba nerve the mutant
that would eventually go on to become
apocalypse and then of course there's
his tie-in to the Young Avengers the
Avengers are originally formed by iron
lad however iron lad is actually a past
alternate version of Nathaniel Richards
aka Kang the Conqueror Kang goes back in
time to visit his past self to stop
bullies from putting him into a coma for
a month but the young Nathaniel Richards
is horrified of what he
so he takes the feature Kings armor and
he runs away he takes his armor and
becomes iron lad and then he forms the
Young Avengers
unfortunately he would eventually
realize that he has to become King and
eventually he does and to top it all off
it also appears that Kang the Conqueror
is going to tie into the Loki series as
well when we got our very very brief
clip of the Loki series during the Super
Bowl we can see Loki wearing a prison
uniform that says TV a on it this stands
for the time variance Authority and the
time variance Authority is responsible
for protecting multiple timelines if
anybody from a timeline or a timeline
itself threatens another timeline their
job is to intervene and in the comics
they've run into Kang the Conqueror many
times although they're never really able
to stop him so it appears that not only
are the Fantastic Four going to be
introduced or set up in ant-man 3 but so
is Kang the Conqueror and Kang the
Conqueror is going to tie the MCU
together in a way that we've never seen
before with the Avengers Young Avengers
x-men and the Fantastic Four
many of the insiders have already
confirmed that Kang the Conqueror is
indeed coming and he will be a villain
of one of the future Avengers films but
much like fan OHS he will be introduced
prior to the actual Avengers film coming
out and that's where ant-man 3 comes in
so what do you think about the Fantastic
Four's introduction and set up in
ant-man 3 and the arrival of Kang the
Conqueror let me know your thoughts and
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe and
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
Marvel for live updates you can follow
me on Twitter and as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof